voilà pour ces débats et ce vote dans
l'hémicycle sur cette proposition de loi
visant à permettre et bien la
célébration de mariages dans les annexes
des mairies le but de ce texte était de
remédier à une petite anomalie du code
civil qui ne prenait pas en compte ces
mariages dans les annexes des mairies
alors que cette pratique est déjà
largement répandue on reste en séance
pour une autre proposition de loi
socialiste toujours sur la famille mais
dans un registre beaucoup plus grave
elle vise à permettre et bien des congés
exceptionnels pour les salariés en cas
de décès d'un proche un parent un enfant
une proposition de loi qui a déjà été
adoptée en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale
en 2011 elle arrive aujourd'hui en
séance vous propose de découvrir tout de
suite les débats et le vote
un monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion de la proposition de loi
adoptée par l'assemblée nationale
tendant à allonger les congés
exceptionnels accordés aux salariés lors
du décès d'un enfant ou d'un conjoint
dans la discussion générale les la
parole est à monsieur françois rebsamen
ministre du travail de l'emploi de la
formation professionnelle et du dialogue
social
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
j'ai remis
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs sur le
rapporteur voilà s'agit donc d'une
proposition de loi qui ont le but
d'allonger les congés exceptionnels
sujet important sensible accordée aux
salariés lors du décès d'un enfant ou
d'un conjoint
c'est donc un sujet comment dire
éminemment sensible qui nous réunit à
cet instant aujourd'hui le décès d'un
proche est toujours une épreuve quelles
que soient les circonstances
une épreuve qui nous a tous touchés
directement ou indirectement et donc il
appartient je le crois en tous les cas à
la société toute entière de manifester
tout attaf tout à la fois sa solidarité
mais aussi son empathie on va dire face
à la douleur d'une mère d'un père ou
d'un conjoint est donc cette solidarité
elle doit se traduire par des droits le
droit notamment à des congés de congés
congé exceptionnel d'une durée que
j'appellerais descente est donc
aujourd'hui la durée légale des congés
pour décès qui est fixée par le code du
travail varie en fonction du lien de
parenté
il s'agit donc de deux jours de congé
pour le décès d'un enfant deux jours
pour le décès d'un conjoint ou la
partenaire du partenaire lié par un
pacte civil de solidarité est un jour
pour le décès d'un père d'une mère d'un
beau père ou d'une belle-mère d'un frère
ou d'une soeur dans tous les cas il faut
le rappeler les congés exceptionnels
pour décès qui sont assimilés à des
jours de travail effectif sont donc à la
charge de l'employeur
et ne peuvent excéder deux jours la
réalité aujourd'hui deux jours beaucoup
d'entre vous ont pensé que c'était
insuffisant vous en conviendrez tous
c'est insuffisant
si l'on compare le nombre de jours
accordés pour un décès au nombre de
jours accordés pour des heureux
événement qui sont bien souvent eu
prévisible quatre jours pour un mariage
trois jours pour une naissance pour
l'arrivée d'un enfant adopté un jour
pour le mariage d'un enfant et j'avoue
que cette différence semble
difficilement compréhensible est
difficilement justifiable et en annulant
cette différence la proposition de loi
dont vous allez débattre répond je le
crois un impératif de cohérence c'est
insuffisant aussi au vu des démarches
beaucoup plus compliqué difficile à
accomplir en cas de décès dans une
situation souvent de choc et de détresse
au delà de l'organisation des obsèques
les formalités administratives sont
nombreuses et complexes et dans ces
circonstances il faut bien reconnaître
qu'elle constitue incontestablement un
poids particulier et donc il faut faire
face aux bouleversements qui peuvent
toucher toute la cellule familiale
organisée par exemple le retour à
l'école des frères et des soeurs et il
faut du temps tout simplement en
accordant aux salariés plus de temps la
proposition de loi répond donc un
impératif d'humanité et de solidarité
pour remédier à cette insuffisance
certaines conventions collectives
prévoient des jours de congés
exceptionnels supplémentaires il s'agit
de branches professionnelles bien sûr
c'est le cas par exemple dans les
branches de la métallurgie ou du
bâtiment ou encore dans les transports
routiers des accords
conclue dans les entreprises peuvent
également le prévoir mais peuvent le
prévoir il ne s'agit là que d'une
faculté est donc en raison ou en
fonction plus exactement de la taille de
la nature de l'entreprise qui les
emploie tous les salariés ne sont donc
pas égaux et non défini n'en bénéficie
donc pas de la même manière ils sont
alors contraints d'utiliser leur quota
de congés annuels pour prolonger cette
période de temps que nécessaire
et s'ils ne parviennent pas à un
compromis soit avec leur employeur ou
avec leurs collègues les arrêts de
maladie
donc ce n'est pas l'objet de vienne
parcours de tels expédients ne sont
satisfaisants pour personne en fixant
une durée descente aux congés
exceptionnels accordés à tous les
salariés
cette proposition de loi répond donc à
un impératif d'égalité cohérence
solidarité égalité
autant de valeurs qui nous appartient de
porter ensemble en partageant le constat
de cette insuffisance du droit et en y
remédiant il n'est bien sûr pas question
de quantifier la douleur nous en serions
bien incapable c'est impossible
il s'agit simplement de donner un peu
plus de temps à ceux qui sont touchés
par le drame ou par le drame qui
représente bien évidemment la perte d'un
enfant ou d'un conjoint
l'octroi de ces jours de congés
supplémentaires n'atténuera en aucune
façon la douleur des familles
ce n'est ni le rôle ni votre pouvoir ni
le pouvoir du législateur mais cela a
permettra cependant d'alléger les
contraintes matérielles qui pèse à cet
instant sur ce moment particulièrement
difficile je me réjouis donc
le groupe socialiste et souhaité
inscrire ce test qui avait été déposé en
2011 par ce groupe à l'assemblée
nationale alors dans l'opposition à
l'ordre du jour du sénat
les auditions qui avait été menée par la
commission des affaires sociales de
l'assemblée avait mis en lumière
puisqu'il s'agit de modifier même si la
modification n'est pas essentiel est
substantiel mais de modifier le code du
travail et donc elle avait mis en
lumière l'unanimité des représentants
syndicaux et associatifs sur cette
question la même unanimité
je le rappelle avait régné d'ailleurs
sur les bancs de l'assemblée lors du
vote le 17 novembre 2011
le gouvernement de l'époque qui est
appartenait à une autre majorité que la
mienne et mon prédécesseur xavier
bertrand en l'occurrence avait
d'ailleurs émis lui-même un avis
favorable
cette proposition porte donc en elle le
sceau du compromis que les
parlementaires en tous les cas je le
sais arrive parfois à trouver sur
certains sujets éthiques ou sur sur
certains sujets particulièrement graves
ont donc il est temps de la transposer
si vous en êtes d'accord
je voudrais simplement attirer votre
attention sur deux points particuliers
la première c'est la simplicité
nécessaire la simplicité nécessaire dans
noces qui figure aujourd'hui dans la
proposition de loi
simplicité car toute autre démarche
serait je le crois difficilement
explicables et ce qui est difficilement
explicable est encore plus difficilement
applicable donc il faut rester sur je
crois un principe de simplicité
et puis je le crois aussi ne pas mais je
m'exprime là en tant que ministre sur ce
sujet si vous souhaitez mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices et
sénateurs si vous souhaitez que cela
entre dans les faits il faut à ce
moment-là voté conforme ce texte car les
calendriers qui s'impose à nous tous et
bien fera que nous repoussons riom ainsi
de plusieurs mois voire de plusieurs
années
une mesure qui je crois avait rassemblé
tout le monde à l'époque et je ne vois
pas pourquoi elle ne rassemblerait pas
tout le monde
aujourd'hui face au drame je vais le
dire comme cela il y as je le crois ni
droite ni gauche ni centre et donc le
gouvernement de l'époque qui était
favorable en 2011 vous l'aurez compris
il l'est encore même si ce n'est pas le
même gouvernement en 2015 je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à monsieur jérôme durand
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues il y a
près de 40 ans les partenaires sociaux
s'accordaient sur la possibilité pour
les salariés de s'absenter de
l'entreprise pour faire face à des
événements importants heureux ou
malheureux de leur vie professionnelle
sans effet sur leur rémunération ni sur
leurs congés
il ya près de neuf ans le sénat a décidé
sur le rapport de son président de la
commission des affaires sociales d'alors
nicolas avoue d'allonger le congé
accordé en cas de décès du conjoint ou
d'un enfant il ya près de trois ans et
demi
l'assemblée nationale par l'adoption
d'une autre proposition de loi déposée
par un à michèle delaunay décidé à son
tour d'allonger ses congés tel est le
parcours singulier du texte aujourd'hui
soumis à l'examen du sénat
cette proposition de loi adoptée en 2011
par l'assemblée nationale porte de deux
à trois jours
la durée du congé en cas de décès du
conjoint ou du partenaire de pacs est de
2 à 5 jours la durée du congé accordé en
cas de décès d'un enfant
quels sont les éléments qui motivent
l'intervention du législateur
je voudrais écarté d'emblée l'idée
d'apporter une compensation de quelques
manières à la douleur ressentie par les
familles combien de temps faut-il pour
affronter un deuil
la loi ne peut avoir de réponse à cette
question
aussi notre commission n'est-elle pas
entrer dans un débat établissons une
hiérarchie pour le moins délicate entre
les épreuves qui peuvent infliger les
salariés tentent elles touchent à leurs
histoires personnelles ou à leur
intimité
elle a simplement considérer qu'un congé
de deux jours était trop bref pour
permettre aux salariés de faire face
dans de bonnes conditions aux
conséquences du décès pour assurer
l'organisation des obsèques notamment
elle a par ailleurs noté que la durée du
congé était moins élevé en cas de décès
des plus proches qu en cas d'événements
heureux mais surtout le plus souvent
visible mariage naissance elle a surtout
souhaité selon la logique de socle
minimal de droit que constitue le code
du travail
rétablir une forme d'équité entre les
salariés couverts par des accords
collectifs souvent plus favorable que le
ministère du travail évalue à 9 5
millions de salariés soit 40 % et ce qui
ne relève d'aucune branches
professionnelles ou d'une branche où le
dialogue social est peu fructueux
naturellement nous aurions pu souhaiter
aller plus loin et apporter davantage de
garanties aux salariés
la question du concubin ou des parents
ou d'autres proches
c'est évidemment posée au cours de notre
réunion de commission de ce matin un
débat s'est instauré partageant nos
collègues
entre ceux qui étaient désireux
d'assurer rapidement des garanties plus
forte aux salariés et ceux qui
souhaitaient les élargir à l'occasion de
l'examen de ce texte quitte en reporter
la mise en oeuvre à titre personnel je
pense que notre première responsabilité
est de faire aboutir rapidement ce texte
voilà quels sont donc les motifs de
l'intervention du législateur
le texte qui nous est soumis a été
amendé en commission des affaires
sociales à l'assemblée nationale à la
différence de la proposition initiale
ils ne distinguent pas selon que
l'enfant est à charge ou non et ne
prévoit pas d'augmentation en cas de
décès d'autres parents proches parents
beaux parents frères et soeurs ainsi
modifié le texte a fait l'objet d'un
très large consensus qui a permis son
adoption à l'unanimité à l'assemblée
nationale le 23 novembre 2011
notre commission soutient cette
amélioration des droits des personnes
affligées par le décès d'un proche et
vous recommande d'adopter ce texte
elle souhaite naturellement que comme
elle l'a fait le 25 mars dernier le
sénat puisse se prononcer à l'unanimité
je vous remercie merci monsieur jérôme
durand dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole d'état madame aline
archimbaud pour six minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires sociales chers collègues le
discutant donc aujourd'hui d'une
proposition de loi qui vise à étendre à
trois jours le congé alloué à un salarié
en cas de décès d'un conjoint ou
partenaire de pacs et à cinq jours en
cas de décès d'un enfant adopté par les
députés en novembre 2011
elle n'est débattu au sénat que trois
ans et demi après
aujourd'hui malgré son caractère
consensuel
monsieur ministre vient de le rappeler
enfin nous pouvons discuter de ce qui
peut paraître être à tort un détail
technique mais qui pour toutes les
familles confrontées au décès d'un
proche qui traverse une période de
grande détresse est d'une grande
importance
la loi prévoit déjà la possibilité pour
un salarié de prendre deux jours de
congés pour événements familiales en cas
de décès d'un enfant d'un conjoint ou
partenaire de pacs c'est tout simplement
un principe d'humanité de solidarité
nationale qui s'imposent mais au regard
de la gravité de ces situations on
comprend bien que deux jours sont
toutefois trop peu pour les personnes
touchées par ces deuils qui ont besoin
de prendre le temps nécessaire afin de
gérer émotionnellement et de façon
pratique la perte d'un proche
les chiffres sont là pour le confirmer
la direction générale du travail estime
en effet que 9 millions et demi de
salariés prennent des congés pour
événements familiaux d'une durée
supérieure à celle prévue par le code du
travail cela conduit donc dans les faits
à chercher des expédients affaire comme
on peut apprendre par exemple des congés
classique pour ceux qui en disposent et
qui peuvent reposer ou des jours de
congés maladie et donc il y a
dans la réalité une exigence d'égalité
nous devons promouvoir cette égalité
c'est ce que fait cette proposition de
loi
proposition de loi qui permet d'être
plus proche de la réalité des situations
des salariés
et qui permettra en plus de rendre plus
homogènes les droits à congés pour les
événements de la vie en l'état actuel
dès textes en effet un événement heureux
comme le mariage ou le pacs par exemple
ouvre droit à quatre jours de congé
alors que les événements dramatiques
comme le décès d'un enfant conjoint ne
permette aux salariés concernés de n'en
prendre que la moitié alors même si dans
l'absolu la entre guillemets
hiérarchisation des liens de parenté qui
donne droit plus ou moins deux jours
peut poser question
et même si certains amendements
effectivement ont été déposées ce matin
après discussion dans notre groupe il
nous paraît évident de soutenir ce
projet de loi est de le voter sans
amendement tout simplement pour qu'il
puisse maintenant rapidement être mis en
application
parce qu'en effet seul le vote conforme
peut permettre qu enfin un projet qui a
maintenant des pauses été déposé il ya
plus de trois ans et demi puisse être
mis en application
nous pensons que devant cette réalité
delà du deuil delà de la souffrance des
drames humains auxquels il est donc ils
étaient bloqués qui sont évoqués là il
est possible dans cet hémicycle de
trouver un consensus et nous proposons
donc tous les collègues de l'ensemble
des groupes quelles que soient les
groupes auxquels nous appartenons puisse
se rassembler sur un sujet qui relève
tout simplement d'une question
d'humanité
je vous remercie merci madame archimbaud
dans la suite de la discussion la parole
est à monsieur dominique watrin pour six
minutes également
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues
chacun connaît pour l'avoir vécu la
douleur qui suit le décès d'un proche
nous leur encore plus vivre lorsqu'il
s'agit d'un membre de sa famille ces
événements qui jalonnent la vie de toute
famille sont inégalement surmonté par
chacune et chacun d'entre nous en
fonction des liens qui unissaient la
personne décédée à ceux qui restent
ils sont d'autant mieux supporter si la
personne peut engager sereinement un
travail de deuil
actuellement l'article l 31 42 1 du code
du travail prévoit des durées variables
d'autorisation d'absence exceptionnel
sans perte de salaire en fonction du
lien de parenté du ou de la salariée
avec la personne défunte
c'est dur et sont souvent très
insuffisante à maints égards
compte tenu des difficultés pour
organiser des obsèques dignes et
accomplir les formalités administratives
les difficultés rencontrées sont
d'autant plus grandes en cas
d'éloignement du salarié et de la
personne décédée ou du lieu prévu pour
les obsèques
si certaines conventions collectives et
la pratique d'employeurs bienveillant
compense les manques du dispositif
législatif
il n'en reste pas moins que nombre de
salariés sont parfois plongés dans la
détresse d'un décès sans bénéficier de
tout l'accompagnement nécessaire ceci
n'est pas acceptable
souvent dans une telle situation les
salariés n'ont pour seule solution que
de demander à leur médecin
un arrêt maladie pour pouvoir assister
aux obsèques
par ailleurs cet article du code du
travail comporte des injustices
inacceptables je vais prendre quelques
exemples comment comprendre qu'un
salarié bénéficie de quatre jours de
congé pour son mariage pour la
conclusion d'un pacte civil de
solidarité
depuis la loi de 2014 mais que le décès
du partenaire du pacs ou du mariage nous
droit à seulement deux jours
congés il ya là une injustice sociale
qui se double d'une rupture d'égalité
entre les salariés du privé les agents
de la fonction publique
nous regrettons par conséquent car la
différence de la proposition initiale de
madame delaunay le texte soit réduit aux
situations de décès d'un enfant ou du
conjoint et partenaires liés par le pacs
la proposition de loi n'évoque plus les
décès des parents et beaux parents ni
des enfants contrairement aux textes de
2011 c'est pourquoi nous soutenons
l'amendement visant à porter à trois
jours la durée du congé exceptionnel
accordé aux salariés en cas de décès du
père ou de la mère
nous regrettons fin la suppression des
jours de congés exceptionnels pour les
enfants la charge des salariés
conscient au final que ce texte manque
d'ambition et ne reste pas moins que ces
dispositions du texte constituent des
avancées non négligeables humaines dont
l'adoption n'a que trop tardé il est
vrai pour cette raison le groupe crc
votera favorablement cette proposition
de loi
merci monsieur dominique watrin la
parole et à monsieur richard barbier
gilbert barbier pardon excusez moi mon
cher collègue
le président du seul ministre le vice
président de la commission le rapporteur
j'ai bien entendu les orateurs
précédents et monsieur le ministre a
bien entendu je pense que chacun ici
partagent problèmes que cela pose en cas
de survenue d'un événement extrêmement
douloureux et il n'est pas ici de juger
la quantité de du malheur et devoir d'y
adapter les jours obtenu aussi je
partage totalement la preuve objective
la proposition de loi de malades launay
qui a été présenté et qui a été comme ça
dit profondément modifiées que ce que je
regrette personnellement mais qui vise
donc ce qu'il en reste d'augmenter la
durée des congés en cas de décès d'un
enfant d'un conjoint et des jeux et deux
jours prévu par le code du travail sont
effectivement bien insuffisant au regard
des démarches qu'il faut entreprendre et
moralement inadaptés comme elle l'avait
rappelé à l'assemblée nationale je
rappelle en 2011 cette situation
contraint les salariés à utiliser les
quotas de congés annuels lorsqu'il ne
réussissent pas à s'entendre avec leur
employeur ou avec leurs collègues et ça
peut conduire à solliciter en arrêt de
travail général c'est ce qui se passe ce
qui n'est pas non plus satisfaisantes
sur l'humanisme pour laquelle de
nombreuses conventions collectives ont
été mises en place avec un régime que
généreux mais tous les salariés ne sont
pas concernés par ces conventions lui
paraît donc légitime d'améliorer ce
régime est bien entendu le texte qui
nous est proposée va dans ce sens
cependant
le texte tel qu'il a été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale je rappelle en
novembre 2011
c'est le fruit d'un consensus mais la
proposition initiale prévoyait d'aller
beaucoup plus loin puisqu'elle traitait
de l'ensemble des congés par décès on a
évoqué ce problème à mon avis il est pas
tout à fait satisfaisant au regard de
l'évolution de la sociologie en effet
tout d'abord moi je déplore que ce texte
ne fasse pas par preuve de la même
indulgence pour le décès d'un père ou
d'une mère
actuellement le congé et d'un jour il
n'est pas l'auraient pas été
déraisonnable je crois de le porter à
trois jours quand on sait que souvent
ces personnes
quelquefois âgées sont dans des maisons
de retraite dans les ehpad et que les
démarches à faire occupe largement plus
d'une plus d'une journée
comment peut-on organiser décemment les
funérailles de son père de sa mère et
effectuer toutes ces démarches
administratives dans le seul espace
qu'une journée ce n'est pas possible
nous le savons bien
par ailleurs le deuxième problème
possibilité d'étendre la trois jours le
congé en cas de décès d'un père du maire
avait été proposé par madame delaunay
j'en appelle mes collègues du groupe
socialiste cumule un ré inscrire dans
leur créneau cette proposition de loi
dont il faut les remercier et madame
delaunay a insisté commission des
affaires sociales à l'assemblée
nationale bon ça avait été un malentendu
je signale que concernant le père et la
mère
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre je rappelle que à l'assemblée
nationale vous-même avait dit en séance
que le texte pourrait être rectifiés par
le sna j'ai repris ce texte
et c'est pour cela que je vous
proposerai tout à l'heure cet amendement
concernant le père et la mère est
également à l'autre problème qui a je
pense été oublié alors est-ce qu'on est
là pour faire des lois à la va vite où
est-ce qu'on est là pour résoudre des
problèmes de société
sachant que je
pour bien travailler je suis bien
d'accord avec vous il faut savoir quand
même que ce première adoption date de
novembre 2011 et que depuis novembre
depuis 1er octobre 2011 notre assemblée
aurait pu saisir puisque c'était quand
même la majorité présidentielle actuelle
qui étaient ici et qui aurait pu
inscrire plus rapidement cette
proposition de loi puisque vous aviez
une partie de la maîtrise de l'ordre du
jour même si le gouvernement intervient
mais toujours est il que je pense que on
va éliminer de cette proposition de loi
les concubins les concubins ne sont pas
conclues dans cette affaire nous sont
exclus ceux qui aujourd'hui alors comme
je les dis ce matin la commission je ne
suis pas ici pour faire l'apologie du
concubinage qu'il soit notoire ou pas
mais toujours est il que je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un mode de vie de
couple qui utilisent cette formule le
mariage pacs 7 mai le concubinage est
quelque chose qui existe chez beaucoup
de personnes
et bien entendu je pense que si on veut
avoir une loi qui soit complète et bien
je pense qu'il faut revenir là dessus je
signale notre parc quand on parle de
d'un lieu d'aller vite que notre
assemblée sur la proposition du groupe
union centriste de l'époque étant des le
bénéfice du congé au cas du décès du
concubin et ça à l'époque c'était
nicolas abou qui était président de
commission des affaires sociales la
situation du salarié qui perd son
concubin ne se distingue guère de celle
d'un salarié dont le conjoint ou le
partenaire de pacs décède le grand
nombre de couples qui vivent en union
libre rend nécessaire une telle
adaptation de noël qui ne représentent
d'ailleurs pas une grande innovation sur
le plan juridique puisque la législation
sociale à 6000 déjà souvent les
concubins à des époux donc je pense que
bien entendu je comprends l'argument qui
me paraît quand même
un peu fallacieux non la mesure où cette
proposition doit 2006 la première
proposition de loi reprise par madame
delaunay c'est tout à son mérite en 2005
et qui traîne depuis quatre ans alors
moi je voudrais bien que ça aille plus
vite mais ce qu'on est là pour faire des
lois qui ne règle pas tous les problèmes
de société mais au contraire de
légiférer d'une manière satisfaisante
donc voilà chers collègues ce propos ce
n'est pas pour faire barrage à l'action
qui est menée monsieur le ministre je
rappelle que concernant le père et la
mère je pense que vous vous êtes
exprimés et à l'assemblée nationale vous
aviez dit que le sénat pouvait revenir
sur cette affaire puisqu'il y avait il
ya eu un espèce de malentendus dans la
discussion
on a mal compris ce qu'était le père et
la mère l'époque je sais pas ça paraît
un peu compliquée toujours est il que je
souhaiterais que les deux amendements
que j'ai présentées dont l'un a été
acceptée par la commission et l'autre
refusé un petit peu adroit puisse être
revenir là dessus et puis peut-être que
on pourra utiliser des procédures assez
rapide et puis que l'assemblée nationale
à ce moment là pourrait peut-être faire
un conforme ce qui permettrait de mettre
rapidement en place cette proposition de
loi fort intéressant merci monsieur
barbier la parole à madame françoise
gatel pour 8 minutes
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues
monsieur le ministre nous évoquons cet
après-midi un sujet qui touche à la part
la plus intime de nos vies personnelles
vouloir satisfaire rapidement ce que
nous appelons tous une nécessité
n'empêche pas de bien faire les choses
et d'entendre les propositions
d'amendement de mon collègue quant à
l'élargissement des propositions qui
sont faites aux concubins et aux parents
alors en préambule de mon intervention
souhaiterait et m un regret quant à la
lenteur parfois du processus
institutionnel en effet nous examinons
aujourd'hui en 2015 une proposition de
loi qui émane de l'assemblée nationale
mais qui reprend un texte voté au sénat
dès 2006 à l'initiative de nicolas abou
ancien sénateur centriste
le sénat avait donc monsieur le ministre
déjà fait preuve de ses grandes qualités
d'anticipation et d'initiative alors
depuis 1978 et effectivement les
salariés bénéficient de congés pour
événements familiaux destiné à leur
permettre de faire face aux événements
les plus importants de leur vie
personnelle qu'il soit heureux comme un
mariage n'est une essence ou affligeant
comme les décès ces congés n'impacte pas
leur rémunération ni leurs droits à
congé haha cogez ces périodes de
permettent aux salariés de faire face à
l'urgence et leur permettent de gérer un
événement de vie personnelle à la fois
sur le plan matériel administratif mais
aussi sur un plan émotionnel et
psychologique
la durée du congé varient ainsi en
fonction de l'événement pour un mariage
droit du travail octroie 4 jours tandis
que pour le décès d'un conjoint ou d'un
enfant
il ne croit que deux jours on ne peut
effectivement que s'interroger sur une
telle répartition
pourquoi prévoir plus de jours de congés
exceptionnels pour un événement heureux
prévue de longue date et seulement deux
jours pour un événement dramatique et
violent par définition d'un anticipable
deux jours sont-ils suffisants lorsque
vous devez gérer les obsèques et les
nombreuses formalités administratives
deux jours sont-ils suffisants quand
vous subissez une épreuve personnelle
qui vous ébranle fortement et bouleverse
votre vie d'un point de vue
psychologique émotionnel est en capacité
de reprendre le travail
deux jours après un événement à ce point
douloureux
la réponse est claire et il sans appel
je crois monsieur le ministre c'est no
il est vrai que souvent un arrangement
est trouvé avec l'entreprise qui fait
preuve de solidarité envers le salarié
prouver mais parfois le dialogue se
révèle difficile avec l'employeur
obligeant le salarié a sollicité un
arrêt maladie auprès d'un médecin
ces démarches ne peuvent que rajouter
des tensions à des personnes violemment
éprouvé
certes on pourrait en période de lourdes
crise économique s'interroger sur
l'instauration de charge supplémentaire
pour les entreprises mais les incidences
de l'allongement de ce congé
exceptionnel semble objectivement trop
circonscrite pour avoir une répercussion
significative sur l'économie ou sur
l'emploi déjà parce que la proposition
de loi votée par l'assemblée nationale
limite le poids de la charge en bornand
l'octroi de congés exceptionnels
supplémentaire au décès d'un enfant ou
d'un conjoint même si je soutiens les
propositions de mon collègue monsieur
barbier et enfin souvent parce que les
conventions collectives ou les accords
de branche accordent déjà des avantages
largement supérieur aux minimas prévues
par la loi
effectivement aujourd'hui en france 9
millions et timide de salariés
bénéficieraient d'application de
convention collective beaucoup plus
généreux le texte que nous examinons
permettra donc d'harmoniser les
dispositions existantes pour chaque
salarié devant affronter un tel drame
familial enfin ce projet ne concerne pas
le secteur public les fonctionnaires
étant régi par des règles propres pour
conclure monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues je rappellerai qu'il n'ya
d'entreprise que par les hommes et les
femmes qui travaillent si l'efficacité
et la performance économique sont une
exigence incontournable
l'humanisme le respect des personnes et
la solidarité sont des valeurs bien
souvent créés au coeur des entreprises
est au coeur des centristes
aussi notre groupe u10 us et votera
cette proposition profondément humaniste
je vous remercie
merci madame françoise gatel
la parole est à monsieur philippe
mouiller pour six minutes
mais monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
alors je tiens tout d'abord à en
préliminaire a félicité le rapporteur
jérôme durain pour son travail pour
s'être engagé en faveur de cette
proposition de loi
cette proposition que nous examinons
aujourd'hui a pour objet de modifier les
articles du code de travail ayant trait
aux congés pour motifs familiaux pour le
décès d'un enfant et pour le décès du
conjoint ou du partenaire lié par un
pacs c'est congé exceptionnel dit
familiaux ont été un truc dans le code
du travail par la loi du 19 janvier 78
il avait été auparavant négocié par les
partenaires sociaux dans le cadre de
l'accord national interprofessionnel du
10 décembre 1977
la loi du 19 janvier ce ne sont sous 18
était venu introduire dans la licitation
une pratique un usage comme cela a déjà
été dit par les différents intervenants
ces propositions de loi déposée par
madame delaunay en octobre 2011 est
soumise à l'examen de notre assemblée
plus de trois ans après son adoption le
23 novembre 2011 par l'assemblée
nationale
et ce à l'unanimité il est étonnant que
le gouvernement n'ait pas songé n'en
serait plus tôt alors de nos travaux
d'autant plus étonnant que cette
proposition vise à croître notamment les
droits des salariés dans un contexte de
vie difficiles en juin 2011 rappelons
également que jean charles taugourdeau
député ump du maine-et-loire avait
déposé une proposition de loi dont
l'objet était également d'allonger les
délais accordés aux salariés dans le cas
d'un décès l' article l3142 1 du code du
travail prévoit que tout salarié
bénéficie sur justification d'une
autorisation exceptionnelle d'absence de
deux jours pour le décès d'un enfant
d'un conjoint ou d'un partenaire lié par
un pacs et d'un jour pour le décès du
père de la mère du beau-père de la
belle-mère dafa ou d'une soeur
l'article suivant du code du travail
prévoit que ces jours d'absence
n'entraîne pas de réduction de la
rémunération qu'ils sont assimilés des
jours de travail effectif pour
l'allaiter manie détermination de la
durée du congé annuel et qui sont
accordés sans condition d'ancienneté
les délais de ses congés pour événements
familiaux nous sommes bien court face
aux bouleversements que peut représenter
la perte d'un enfant ou de son conjoint
et il est assez surprenant que les
évènements tels qu'une naissance un
mariage un remariage ou
plus jours d'un pacs moments heureux par
excellence prévisible programmables
puisse faire bénéficier finalement les
salariés d'un congé plus long de trois
ou quatre jours en fonction de la nature
de l'événement alors que la perte d'un
enfant
événement imprévisible car concert à
l'ordre naturel des choses représente
une douleur incommensurable ou la
disparition soudaine d'un conjoint ne
donne lieu qu'à deux jours de congés
exceptionnels
ces deux jours paraissent dérisoires
pour ne serait-ce préparer les
funérailles procéder aux formalités
administratives aux démarches diverses
et variées avant de réaliser la perte de
l'être cher et que ne vienne le temps du
deuil
les salariés peuvent trouver auprès de
l'employeur ou leurs collègues de la
compréhension de la compassion et
peuvent prolonger ces deux jours s'en
prenant selon jean de congés sans
bénéficiant d'un arrêt maladie
ces situations bien heureusement
présente à caractère exceptionnel au
sein d'une même entreprise mais nous
devons envisager les hypothèses où le
salarié ne peut être soutenu dans son
milieu professionnel
ainsi dans cette proposition de loi il
est proposé d'allonger les délais donc
pour le décès d'un enfant de trois à
cinq jours et les délais pour le décès
du conjoint ou du partenaire lié par un
pacs également de deux à trois jours ce
matin concept évoqué tout à l'heure un
amendement déposé par notre collègue
gilbert barbier adopté en commission
étant le bénéfice de ce délai de trois
jours au concubin du salarié alors
certes cet amendement s'il était adopté
vous le verrez le calendrier législatif
comme vous l'avez évoqué monsieur le
ministre mais c'est aussi de la
responsabilité responsabilité de votre
gouvernement de prévoir l'espace temps
nécessaire pour faire adopter ce texte
est je crois que cette précision était
fondamental donc je serai amené on ne
soit emmené à soutenir
en tous les cas l'amendement de notre
collègue barbier
cette proposition de loi permettra une
certaine harmonisation dans le secteur
privé ensuite